colin what's going on well i've got a
situation i've got a
i own a small uh service based carpet
cleaning business
um i'm an owner operator started about
three and a half years ago
very cool man that's a whole other story
i got fired from a job and i was tired
of getting fired so i started my own
business and it's been amazing so
hey so would you fire yourself are you
have you turned into a pretty good
employee
you know for the reason i got fired was
i was it was lack of
performance in a sales job yeah and uh i
said you know
in this environment it just wasn't it
wasn't the right fit for me so i said
man i
i need to start my own business so i did
it and it's been it's been incredible
well good good for you man all right so
you got a carpet cleaning business
management has always been restructuring
in your life that's my good will hunting
reference
and but now you got your own place and
you're crushing it so what's up
yep so i gotta nest you this is this is
the this is kind of the emotional uh
concern i have
because i listen to a lot of business
books and tactical stuff like that of do
this do that
here's a budget here's this anyway i've
got a nephew
21 years old he's coming out of prison
of the last three years
i would love to help him out in some way
to bring him on and and and
work in the business with me and kind of
be a a mentor if i
if you will his sister or my sister his
mom and i are
super close like we're and so she's just
concerned for him and
and i and i want to know like what's the
best way i can help him
but also not jeopardize the integrity of
what i've built
what we've what we've built as a team
and a culture here with with my business
because coming from a background of of
theft and burglary
yep i'm hoping that he's had a a come to
jesus moment
but we're in people's homes we're in
people's businesses
they trust us with door codes and keys
and and
all kinds of stuff that we've built the
reputation for how do i help him
but not jeopardize what we've what we've
built
sounds like you don't want to hire him
but
you think it would help him that's
exactly okay so hiring him
would cause you to treat him
with a little more scrutiny with a
little closer eye
with probably a little less of a leash
than you do your other employees or than
with yourself
which then would cause that relationship
to strain further and a partridge in a
pear tree is that fair
ah yeah so here there's there's really
two ways you can do it number one
you when he gets out you could say you
could sit him down and say i'm gonna
take the risk of a lifetime because i'm
gonna gamble my entire thing on you
because yeah and you tell them what you
just told me a hundred percent of my job
is based on trust
there's a million different carpet
cleaners and i don't i don't know if you
guys are just
if there's like a michael jordan of
carpet cleaning you may be it right
my guess is like at the end of the day
the tools or the tools and the chemicals
or the chemicals
it comes down to do i show up on time do
i
leave this place do i do good work
obviously but am i a pleasure to do
business with
am i fair and honest right all those
things you've built up over the last
three years right
absolutely 100 so sitting down and
saying
you can take all of this from me with
one stupid move
and i'm gonna go all in on you and trust
you
and he can say i'm gonna rise to the
challenge i've learned my lesson this
will never happen
i'm a changed person so colin i'll tell
you this
i was a little punk thief
when i was a kid okay a punk thief
okay and i had some
things happen in my life i never went to
jail um i never stole on a big scale or
anything like that
right i was always taking kids baseball
card i was just a punk man
and dude there are a few things
that get me more fired up on earth than
a thief now
than someone who steals oh absolutely
okay so i'm telling you that to tell you
i have had a change of heart a massive
one
and now um i do whatever i can to make
sure that
that level of integrity is whole in my
life
right comically so to the point that my
friends and family are like dude it's
just 14 cents you don't have to take it
back to the store
we're all getting back in the car we're
going back to the store right so i want
to tell you
change does happen right people do grow
i wouldn't do this job if it wasn't for
that
the other side of that is is day two out
of jail the day
to start that i don't know you know him
right
the other thing you can do besides
sitting him down and being that honest
with him and then going all in on him
which i don't know there's a wrong move
i get from you that you don't think
that's the right one but you can do that
or you can sit them down and tell them
you've got six months you've got one
calendar year i want you to go work your
butt off i want you to show us
right not punitively i want you to show
us who you've become
yeah and then i'll be ready when you're
ready or you can
take him to lunch or to breakfast once a
week and mentor him that way hey how are
things going how are you
are you plug does that make sense and
you can pour
into them in other ways instead of just
you've been fired a lot
right you've had you've had ups and
downs in your life
you can talk to him about getting
knocked down and getting back up right
you've got a lot to offer besides just a
job
here's my interesting question what's
your sister
want you to do what's she saying
you know she was she was very
apprehensive she said hey
she goes she started the conversation
you can say no to this
but essentially can you is there any way
you can help
ah there you go and i said and i said
and
and she's not she's not looking for a
handout she she want like she actually
called the police
and put him in jail before wow okay so
so we're coming from
we're coming from a place where we're
not we're not afraid to beat him up
yeah but in in in a good way like look
if you you mess up
like don't don't put me don't put our
our lives in jeopardy by
your silly decisions you're not you're
not afraid to hold him accountable which
is awesome he's he's blessed to have you
guys that's cool
um so correct what do you think the
right move is
you know the suggestion you made was one
of the exact suggestions i i told my
sister i said look
i said i love him like i i enjoy
spending time with him
as as a young man but again that was
three years ago sure and so
um he literally is not even out of out
of prison yet
but it's supposed to be the next in the
next week or so but anyway with that
being said
um i told her i said look i said he's
got to show
before unless he's directly next
to me like in my eyesight i will
never send him on a job by himself for
at least a calendar year
okay and he messes up one time
like i've got i've i've i've got to let
him go
yeah and so or or like you were saying
like he's got to prove himself somewhere
else where
he's not he's somewhere else for a full
calendar year before i even bring him on
and take him into people's homes how old
is he
he's 21 21. so he's
he's a in the eyes of the law he's a
grown man he's still a kid
right and if he's been in jail for three
of the last years he's he's still a
child
right he had to grow up and learn hard
stuff right i would recommend having
this conversation with his mom in the
room
and you know what would be really great
for everybody is for you to call out
how uncomfortable this is for everybody
to let him know hey your decisions have
potentially put a wedge between me and
one of the women i love the most in the
world which is my sister
because i want to help you and she's
desperate for you to get some help
but now because of your decisions we
love you
but now i'm in a weird spot because my
business is all based on trust
and so i'm gonna lay out the boundaries
here one calendar year
or six calendar months or whatever it is
sure you meet with me every other week
for a year
you make a budget with me let me know
that you are making
good solid decisions you don't miss work
at your new job
dude you're going to come on and me and
you are going to take over the world
with our carpet cleaning business
right but i'm going to invest in you but
i'm not just going to
hand it out to you as you walk out
because this is about trust and you
that's what you got to earn back right
and man i think by just laying it all
out there that keeps you and your sister
from getting crossed with one another
because he's gonna get out it's gonna be
hard for him to find the job that's the
reality
and then she's gonna start getting more
frustrated with you and more frustrated
with you right
and this is just a way to clear that
deck right
away everybody's in the room everybody
knows my plan is i'm gonna stick to this
plan
and then he's cool you're cool and he
may say dude i wanna work carpet clean
and you say
high five brother we're still gonna i'm
still gonna have breakfast with you
whatever right
um yeah but you're able to hold your
head up high put some boundaries in
there and let him know he's loved and
he's connected and and purchasing a pear
tree and my hope is
two years from now you guys have the
most dominator
carpet cleaning business on planet earth
just you two rocking and rolling
right that would be ideal i love your
heart and i love
not only your heart but your rational
thinking how do i best love him not how
do i best just make everybody feel good
really quick and then potentially lose
my business lose my sister lose my
nephew in the process right good for you
good for you
let me know how this goes as you all
have that conversation as you move on
down the road
i'm rooting for you i'm rooting for him
that's awesome